foreign
[Applause]
school children raising their voices in
protest one day after Brazil announced
its plan to fight organized crime
the government says it will invest 180
million dollars in equipment
intelligence and increased cooperation
among Security Forces with the intent of
reducing violence
but in Rio de Janeiro's favelas or slums
there is fear these teenagers say
they're afraid they'll be killed in
police raids like their friend
thirteen-year-old Thiago menezes
any child walking in the Favela can be
killed just because we are not wearing a
t-shirt or shoes policemen can say they
mistook us for criminals and shoot us
was shot dead by policemen two months
ago while riding a motorcycle one of 28
children and teenagers killed by police
forces this year in the state of Rio De
Janeiro all of them in poor
neighborhoods oh boy there's nothing
like the pain of a mother who loses her
child but what hurts more is the
Injustice that police have no right to
shoot and kill and then ask questions
after my son many other children were
killed residents in poor neighborhoods
like this live in constant fear of
police raids and shootouts with criminal
gangs but in now first of violence last
month in the northeastern state of Bahia
shocked Brazilians more than 70 people
were killed in police operations
Brazil's forces say they're badly paid
and equipped to deal with shootouts
among increasingly organized and armed
drug lords
these images recently aired by Brazilian
television show drug cartels training
their soldiers in a sports court right
next to a school and a daycare center in
the complex one of Rio de Janeiro's most
violent slums
what we have seen in recent years are
emergency police operations but what
Brazil needs is a continuous action plan
a plan involving all levels of
government which will also invest in
Social measures like education and
Healthcare it is the only way to reduce
violence which is affecting the most
vulnerable
chiago's parents say they hope their
son's death has not been in vain and
that other children may have a future in
Brazil
Rio de Janeiro
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera